foreign
[Music]
enough talk let's go
you don't want to do this what this
now move
are you down [ __ ] move
[Music]
no no no no no
[Applause]
no
this is our our Santa Claus yeah it is
to whom am I speaking well for tonight
I'm Mr Scrooge now what is it that you
want exactly Santa I want you to put
down your weapons
I want you to let this family go and
then I want to find my reindeer and I
want to continue delivering my presence
all right who the hell are you really
some security guard who's watched so
many action flicks loser X cop s [ __ ] in
the mall playing dressing with
that you're more complicated than that
man not to me it's not because I want to
make it my personal mission my holiday
to-do list to find you and to end you
that is it
a terrible thing to want for Christmas
maybe you and I should discuss that in
person
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
hello
Santa
yes Sarah
daddy said you were very busy tonight
I'm on a break
who who am I speaking
my name is Judy leipester
oh there's two Batman with guns watching
us
they get you out of there
guys on my naughty list
I'm gonna take a lump of coal
each and every one of them and shove it
straight up the ass
well come on so we want to keep on the
nice list you know
sorry can I say butthole then
borderline
a bunch of new bad guy showed up there
on the naughty list
I'm sorry I think this is it kid no
don't say that naughty list
rows and grows
this time Santa if you could have
anything in this world
what would it be
I wish I could see Mrs Claus again
I don't know how much I love her
then you make that wish come true
no no
[Music]
he said these guys they're naughty and
what'd you do to the naughty ones I give
my love a call yeah give them their
lumps
take that call and shove it straight up
their anuses yeah
another one oh so vertical so I'd like
to change that
[Music]
oh
bitter point
you just get off
I'm taking a break between shifts I
guess you could say you ain't driving
are you I steer a little but the Rangers
of my sword
you ain't driving are you I steer a
little but the reindeer to mazur
this is my full fear of the center how
about you
I started the whole damn thing
excuse me
we decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline
Santa Claus himself
all right revelers welcome to your worst
Christmas shopping let's go
foreign
you have 300 million dollars in your
personal vault
one for Christmas
[Music]
I don't want any trouble okay
Something's Gonna scooch up that chimney
Santa are you there
daddy said you were very busy tonight
[Music]
are you gonna help us Santa
no my nice list
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
time for some Seasons beatings
who the hell are you
Boss what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
he's Batman
they're all minority
that's naughty
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my mom for a call
where is this
I believe in you Santa
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
the violent Santa Claus movie
Santa Claus is coming
this Santa is very different than
anything you've ever seen like this
Santa has baggage 10 000 years past of
him giving out toys he creates this
commercialist horrible world where kids
just want more and more and more I
better get going presents aren't going
to deliver themselves
kind of stumbles across his house and if
there's a little girl in there it's
still believes in Christmas it still
believes in Santa that is a direct
hotline of Santa Claus himself I can
talk to Santa Trudy you'll always
believe in him no matter what hello
Santa
welcome to your worst Christmas ever
Santa Witnesses Trudy in an extreme
situation he has no choice but to act
Santa
keep watching us are you gonna help us
yeah no my nice list you've been a very
good girl this year it's like two movies
one this crazy die-hard trapped in a
house burst scenaries Vault underneath
300 million dollars and then you have
Miracle on 34th Street movement and they
just sort of like smashed together
truly's trying to help Santa to get his
Christmas spirit back it kind of just
warms your heart they're naughty
boy I give my alarm for call give them
their lumps
it's all you can eat Byron's Gore
hilarity might be the real Santa
really touching and moving in great
freaking action
[Applause]
it's a friend Mr Claus please call me
Santa
thank you
foreign